so no matter what time of year it is ice
cream is always the perfect way to treat
yourself
and your family tomorrow is national
sunday day it's wednesday but hey we can
eat whenever we want
rocky is live for us at sloan's ice
cream giving us a head start to where to
celebrate hiraki
hey david okay so because sloane's is
top 10
ice cream shops in the u.s okay first
and foremost but also you guys
should come celebrate here because it's
a toy store too so
david i want to let you know i brought
you something this is for you because
you are a boss so i'll bring this to you
after after the show here um but let's
get into the ice cream okay because
we'll show you all the rest of the shop
in a second the ice cream here is unique
it's not your basic sundae right america
so you're gonna have different type of
flavors we have different type of
chocolate vanillas and all of that
uh-huh the thing is it's gonna be
high-quality ice cream that means
sixteen percent more
body fat and it's gonna have 50 less air
okay a little bit more rich and then
some flavor
and they also taste homemade right
that's something really special about
you guys made flavor see
we do batch by best we would not do like
a whole machine to do a lot
i love that so the good thing about this
is that you will have unique flavors
like carrot cake
okay vanilla cream cheese ice cream
uh-huh and we blend in the carrot cake
in it
okay um cookie monster will be next to
it it will be homemade chocolate chip
cookies
oreo that will be my cookies and cream
amazing and then i have like fresh
strawberry
i have circus it will be cotton candy
gummy bears like apple pie
oh my gosh vanilla ice cream everything
that you could imagine this is what i
call
or what you've been called uh ice cream
utopia and that is that couldn't be more
accurate so since we have a plethora of
flavors here also for your dogs by the
way
yeah homemade treats for your dog so
just in case you guys are watching who
has dogs
at home okay so we have some flavors
here i'm gonna go ahead and choose one
to taste
so over don't tell me don't tell me
don't tell me
oh shoot that's okay okay i can't do
that one so i'm gonna go with this blue
flavor oh my god
all right you guys ready yeah all right
what is this
blue ice cream
cotton candy yes it is this is delicious
i don't actually usually like cotton
candy but that is good
okay so on top of just the ice cream
you can get your sundaes okay
because tomorrow is national sunday day
please describe this
beautiful creation we're gonna have five
scoops of ice cream of your choice
okay so we do provide samples vegan so
you can make that
and then you're gonna have fresh cookie
in it we have m m cookies or peanut
butter cookies
it has three wet toppings hot fudge hot
caramel what one is in it
oh my god oh shoot dry chopping with
your whipped cream and your decoration
can you so i got to bring this back to
the station somehow before it goes but
you gotta eat it with the with the
shovel that's how big it is okay so
coming up later in the show i'm gonna
show you what the kitchen sink sunday
means
i'm a little scared i'm a little scared
i'll send it back to you guys
i need a wheelbarrow to take out that
kitchen sink ice cream whatever that's
going to look like all right we'll see
in the next half hour